[Musique]
une tête de jeune fille émergent de la
rivière qui traverse bilbao en espagne
pour surprendre les habitants
l'installation a eu lieu de nuit au
matin de nombreux passants se sont
arrêtés devant cette installation
déroutante une oeuvre immergés ou
visible selon les heures de la journée
et les marais pour l'artiste mexicain à
l'origine de cette sculpture ce visage
c'est celui de nos défis en matière
d'environnement selon nos actions soit
nous coulons soit nous sortons la tête
de l'eau
baby doc bla bla bla bla bla bla bla
bareback better bla bla bla
[Applaudissements]
franchement
c'est quoi c'est quoi
[Musique]
rocé quoi ici
c'est quoi
c'est quoi c'est la crotte
ça y ressemble
et distribuer de la crotte aux chevaux
alors effectivement j'ai l'impression
qu'ils viennent parce qu'ils pensent que
je vais leur donner à manger mais c'est
pas tout à fait le cas c'est moins
qu'ils qui les prend de leur matière
première à vous ramasser la crotte je
ramasse leurs crottes effectivement le
crottin le crottin pardon ce qui me fait
halluciner c'est que les deux cas cela
elles sont nickel en fait voilà par
contre autour c'est maladie la voilà
[Musique]
je n'ai jamais vu ça de toute ma vie
nulle part donc pour ramasser le
croquant des pottok oui oui et vous quoi
faire de la pop atteint de la cua on va
popoter de la popote de la popote way de
la bonne popote à faire une grande soupe
il manque un petit peu plus un
roman
tout en gardant le ballon mais ce
classique vous avez mis quoi dans votre
reee pour que vous mettre dans cet état
[Musique]
c'est impossible je peux pas je peux pas
mais c'est impossible les gars message
clair pour nous car c'est un dossier eva
c'est l'avion spatial aussi peur de cet
avion pour moi c'est panique à bord
tétanisés c'est facile pour eux yamada
qui a eu à piment et gignac il ya eu des
petits beurres
ga cerveau taille humaine mais c'est
impossible les sondages pour la
présidentielle que vous allez découvrir
avec nous regardez bien les intentions
de vote dans mais voilà les mecs qui a
pas un truc plus clair
que vous êtes voilà mettez moi ça aimons
bien un truc favard bac + 18 pour le
regarder cette bande de fous moi qui
sont la cible commentatrice d'un homme
alors ne venez pas quelqu'un alors ne
venez pas mais c'est vous n'est pas
grave n'est pas faire du commentaire du
dc c'est pour défaire nombre fini moi si
vous voulez comprendre des sujets de
fond ce avec non je parle pas du jeu
parle d'abord des sujets que je décide
oui mais c'est de sujets c'est aimer
choisi le sujet s'est émoussée
migratoire de ce nom à l'incroyable ça
devient difficile
les amis d'eric zemmour va falloir
changer le nom de l'émission tpm vous
aide à vous et moi haut la main ça c'est
bien ça c'est alors ils sont tous
contents
ça me touche pas mon job
[Applaudissements]
ce
qui m'intéresse c'est de comprendre le
phénomène emo le sujet que vous dites
est extrêmement intéressant mais c'est
parce que je traite pacifique jeudi
celui que vous avez choisi de diffuser
durant a non mais elle se barre à rennes
elle se bat pas pour cette idée est la
raison donc si je devine est éliminé ok
ça vous fait ça je joue le jeu
et les chocottes j'ai super peur alors
[Musique]
car
vous trouverez vous devant votre gentil
pas
bouder
[Musique]
moi j'ai d'autres j'ai du coup de carol
amar tou et
[Musique]
feuille de nori
merci
coûte maintenant vous goûtez le reste
maintenant attention à parit à paris
avec moi j'y tiens moi je respecte
toujours mes engagements tu as voulu
jouer tu as perdu oui mais faut goûter
quand même tu as perdu donc on n'a pas
le score d'anne hidalgo là
dans la salle on est sous les noms
arrête avec ça
arrête avec ce contrat cadre d'un goal à
23 mais non c'est nul ça on le voit
cette merde enlever quoi cette merde
c'est classe est évincé des cinq sens et
déjà suite de poids ou là je comprends
pas il part il a même pas goûté mon plat
et ou disparus
partis
j'ai jamais été aussi loin mais j'assume
ce que j'ai dit un pari est un pari même
si j'avoue que pour jouer son concours
comme ça il faut en avoir dans le vide
attention la séquence va très vite
[Musique]
au ralenti elle a tout d'un miracle sur
une route de darwin en australie une
voiture a traversé huit voies de
circulation sans faire de blessé la
vidéo diffusée par les services de
secours s'arrête là mais le véhicule a
fini sa course dans les locaux d'une
entreprise la conductrice qui a perdu le
contrôle était accompagnée de son enfant
au moment de l'accident et personne ne
présente de blessures graves
mourir peut-être rendre 25m james bond
est le tout dernier pour daniel craig on
voit tout ça fait alors tapis rouge
[Applaudissements]
des drapeaux verts et non pas sur un
tapis ou alors on va se recaler on va
aller autant ce james bond il se fait
attendre ça fait deux ans avec le comice
donc on patiente encore un petit peu moi
je me blanc n'est pas chez ikea c'était
un matin et un simple coup d'oeil suffit
pour lui donner envie de passer son
chemin
[Musique]
on va aller se faire la suite de la
visite mais je suis en train de je suis
en train d'halluciner aussi sur l'état
des murs en fait bah oui regardes tu vas
de tout ces trucs noir surtout salle
assez impressionnant oui je sais ce que
c'est ça ça c'est des crottes de vivre
tout simplement j'ai encore peur de
manger des insectes
à part ce que vous pensiez que les
congolais ne se nourrissait
exclusivement que des insectes et vous
sortez sa double vie